and you feel like you're strapped to
this crazy person you're like oh no
i'm like this i'm in a car and the
driver of the car
is completely insane and it's going to
take us all down
yes what have i done with my life
[Music]
this is michael seibel with dalton
caldwell today we're going to talk about
whether you are being too optimistic or
too pessimistic about your startup so
dalton set this topic up we we certainly
meet many founders who fall in
either of these categories pretty
regularly yeah i mean
the fact is you need to be both
optimistic and pessimistic okay and
if you're too far on either extreme
you
are going to fail
right um that's
simple so to start with
why don't you let's talk about the
comical stereotype of someone that's too
pessimistic and we know these people so
what is it like paint me the picture
michael
who's the stereotypical
two pessimistic founder what are they
like
it is like one painful experience
causes them to want to either quit
everything or change everything and fill
in the blank on the painful experience
it's like
yeah bad customer call
bad investor pitch meeting
talk to a friend like whatever whatever
it is talk to an advisor but like
one
negative experience is getting them to
run away
yeah it's like uh
eeyore or something i don't know if
that's too weird of a reference but you
know woe is me
everything everything bad is happening
to me
you know the world's out to get me
everything that could go wrong is going
wrong
and everything's going to [ __ ] and
they're screwed like it's just nothing
nothing good can happen to me that is
what talking to a two pessimistic
founder is like how about the comical
stereotype type of someone who's too
optimistic what's it like talking to
them so at first you get really excited
you're like there must be something here
but the longer they keep talking the
more you are extremely confused why it
doesn't appear
like anything has happened like any
values been created or any insight has
been found
and then like at some point you start
asking questions because you're assumed
that
you're the idiot
but by the end of the conversation like
you are convinced the person actually
has no idea what they're doing that's
never happened to us before though
that's all theoretical
yeah it's like talking to someone that's
um had too much coffee or is medicated
or something where
everything is great everything is
wonderful
everyone is out to help them
like the the planets are aligning
you know like their startup is the best
thing ever
and then again yeah you ask questions
you're like wait this song sounds kind
of bad
aren't you worried about some of this
stuff and they're like no no this is all
going according to plan this is like
this is really good and so again in both
extremes here
there are problems okay
there and not only that they multiply
when you have god forbid you have
employees right like then it's then it's
even worse
i think it's helpful to do this
self-diagnosis if you're too optimistic
pessimistic to put yourself in the shoes
of your employees and imagine
who would you want to work for who would
you think would be like a good leader
because to answer this i think a good
leader is an optimist they believe if
they don't believe they're a horrible
leader like right right out of the gate
a pessimistic leader who doesn't believe
that things can work
quit not like that ain't gonna like
that's a bad leader so you're you're
you're off the team okay on the other
hand though
a two pessimistic sorry too optimistic
leader
has horrible plans
their plans are like involve
magical things happening
rainbows and ponies and space time
travel and like like
like like if you listen if you actually
listen to the over optimistic person's
plans any reasonable employee be like
wow
this person has lost their minds they
have no idea what's going on here and
and it becomes a little scary when your
leader sounds like that suddenly you're
like oh god like are we even gonna get
the basics right
when this person doesn't seem to be
tethered to any
land mass at all
are we you know
the person said two months ago that our
company was great and we were all gonna
be rich and now
they're saying you know the funding fell
through but they have a solution
am i are we gonna even make payroll
yes like you you lose your credibility
in like two seconds
yes you make that perfect point like
when you cross over being too optimist
your employees start questioning
everything
like you you lose all trust because
they're like oh crap like
if if the if the leader can't see this
obvious thing right in front of their
face
uh oh like what what like what else have
i not uncovered yet on what the leader
can't see and and you feel like you're
strapped to this crazy person you're
like oh no
i'm like this i'm in a car and the
driver of the car
is completely insane and is going to
take us all down
yes what have i done with my life so
those are the extremes right so if
you're probably pessimistic
it ain't gonna work it's over like no
one you know like packing up and if
you're too optimistic
it's probably over two so what do you do
or like how do you self-diagnose michael
like i'm sure people are always whenever
we say things like this people like well
how do i know which one applies to me
let's give let's start with pessimistic
yeah so you might be too pessimistic so
this happens all the time in yc
you sent a shitty email
to a hundred customers that wasn't
personalized you didn't send it to the
right person you sent it in the middle
of the night it had typos your call to
action was like
would you like to join me for a six hour
phone call to discuss this further
and you only got like
five replies
oh my god the world's coming to an end
we pro our startup doesn't work because
a hundred potential customers with email
didn't produce 100 leads
we get this like every batch and we have
to be like
it's going to be fine folks
i think expectation setting i think when
you i think you could be too up you
could be too pessimistic
if you can't
if you don't if anything short of
absolute unmitigated success right out
of the gate doesn't happen and you're
like
you know you're like oh man this isn't
working out for me i'm really worried
it's like poor expectation setting and
so i think a lot of folks just they
don't realize that this stuff is hard
and then even when it's working you
mostly get no's and so that's the way
you might be
pessimistic is
it doesn't immediately work who knew
these things take longer than immediate
to work
so there's a lot of variance on this
right like i would argue the next one
that i see all the time is
i talked to an investor i talked to a
friend or i talked to a customer
and they said this wasn't going to work
and and i take that to mean like i
ascribe god-like predictive powers to
one of those three people and think i
need to quit or do something else
because an investor a friend or a
customer said this wasn't going to work
as opposed to thinking let's go through
the list your friends are idiots and
don't know anything especially if they
would never use your product
investors are close seconds as idiots
especially if they never use your
product don't invest in your space
aren't good investors don't invest a lot
of companies
and then your customer might not be an
early adopter or god forbid you might
have mis
misidentified
the customer and you might be pitching
someone who would never be a customer no
matter what
so like you know
just like
one negative signal is does not mean
you can't build a startup like or this
product's not going to work this idea is
not going to work
one last one
that i want to throw in because uh i
find it really interesting
we help founder set goals for yc
what's the goal i want to accomplish by
the end of yc we called the demo diggle
and i'm constantly seeing founders who
don't accomplish that goal thinking
their company is dead oh we didn't
accomplish our demo day goal we didn't
accomplish our goal for the next three
months obviously this is a bad company
and they missed the whole point we're
like
and it's really funny now because i
actually wrote this in the advice we
give the founders in the batch but they
still miss the point like
setting the aggressive goal the purpose
was to get you to move fast to get you
to go go go like
it was the it was the juice like
if you learned a bunch pursuing that
goal you got value even if you didn't
accomplish it um but like so many
founders kind of go into the demo day
season being like we didn't accomplish a
demolited gold does that mean our
company sucks it's like
no
not even a little bit
it's all some version of
gave up too early
or wants to give up you're too
pessimistic if you want to give up too
early or if you expect it to be really
easy for you or you think it's easier
for everyone else you have like a
victimization thing well everyone else
has it easier than me the world's out to
get me
you know i don't think that's that means
you're being too pessimistic um
ultimately
you can redirect your energy if things
aren't working
but you shouldn't give up
fast like i don't know how to articulate
it like like two founders that are too
pessimistic the way you know they're
being too pessimistic is they freaking
give up
it's
obvious when they're too pessimistic
and they bring everyone down
they're co-founders like everyone around
them talks to them
and feels
worse after talking to them
and deflated
yeah
and and like last thing on this like we
talk about the synonyms oic of the
difference between being high energy and
low energy it's like the eor thing
like
you want to talk to someone and get
energy when they're telling you about
their company
and
walk away from the conversation be like
yeah that person's like gonna do things
like i'm excited to talk to them
if talking to you is deflating
again this is not pejorative but it's
like that's a sign you're too
pessimistic that like yes trying to
express what you're working on what
problems you want to solve
cause people
to feel drained
yes
but let's be clear i think that the cool
thing about being too pessimistic like
i love your opinion on this because i
actually think i rather help someone
being too pessimistic strangely because
usually
when i try to help introduce realistic
expectations
they can adjust
you know usually
we just need to tell them what's
reasonable and suddenly they're like oh
okay i guess things aren't as bad as i
thought
all right so
like we said
pessimism sucks but it's curable
optimism is a little harder
and i might argue
maybe the reason why optimism is a
little harder is because we're kind of
saying that the good point is optimistic
so
if you're too
optimistic about your startup you're
like
way off in the never never land and like
that's a harder thing for us to uh to
that's a harder thing for us to cure so
why don't you introduce the the audience
to this concept of magical thinking this
is something you talk about to the whole
batch and i think it's one of the best
talks
yeah
the term i use is is magical thinking um
i think it's like a like a psychology
term but
um and yeah i think it's used in more of
a clinical setting so this is not the
technical technical definition that's
just my founder version of magical
thinking
magical thinking is where you start to
believe
you live
like in a magical world with magical
causes and effects
and that like
things that aren't rooted in reality are
true for you and so an example of like a
magical thought is
hey
if i was in an airport and i saw michael
in the airport and i could like approach
him and pitch my startup he would
immediately see
what a brilliant idea i have
and
you know get out of his checkbook and
like fly me away from my life
and help advise me
to become the next google
okay
so like some people think that way and
that's like completely nuts
right like don't do this
well by the way i think they extend that
thought to that's how companies get
funded like they extend that thought
beyond themselves to believing that's
how the
world works
like the people who get funding get
lucky like that or like do that so i
have to do it too
and they don't bother actually studying
how the world really works yeah or or
like they've watched too many
romantic comedies or something you know
it's like they think their life is a
movie and they're the main character
where like
if they do some really complex
acts showy act that's dramatic and like
something you would see in a movie
if you literally do that like somehow
it's gonna work out for you again you
know what i'm saying like there's lots
of versions of this but it's like
someone that's not rooted in actual
cause and effect of reality and can't
tell the difference between
normal cause and effect like hey the way
you meet michael is you apply to yc on
the website
and then like
we're just normal people and you know
like it's like actually pretty
straightforward
um but when you start to believe that
there's like
magical ways to break into whatever
you know so anyway that's my definition
and there's there's
more subtle versions of this but the
whole concept of magical thinking is
a poor grasp of how the world actually
works
so let's talk about this in the context
of startups
you know how does this come up when
we're talking to founders
how does magical thinking pop its rear
its head up
i mean i think to start with it's
to always have excuses
like when you ask people direct
questions
everything involves a very complicated
answer and excuse about why they can't
grow why they can't get customers why
it's hard for them to get customers
why somehow
there's a complicated story it's other
people's faults that they can't do
something
and all these other people are plotting
against them and like like basically
they're telling a story where they're
the main character they're the hero of
the story and their startup is great and
if it weren't for all these danged
external parties
doing bad things it would be working
right again like put this into practice
of like why people can't
get a customer for instance
that's a big one i think it also comes
up in investing a lot it often comes up
in the
if only i had money
like everyone else does
i'd be able to go do this other thing
like you know people like telling the
story about other companies getting
breaks and them not getting breaks
or telling the story that like
that break that magical moment's like
one step ahead
we'll go from like zero to 100 in just
one step
um
that one's extremely frustrating because
it's just like
it's a complete misunderstanding of how
this game works
what else are you
what else are you seeing in terms of
like
this often happens in product where like
someone has a magical version of their
product in their head
like what do you see in that context
yeah i think
in practice
if you can't build a product and you
don't have a tech co-founder or whatever
or you
have never once built a product and
given it to anyone
and you think it's going well
you are too optimistic like it's not
going well
like sorry
again think about how many people over
the years that have pitched us like it's
a new social network
and it doesn't exist but i but it's like
facebook and tick tock and it's with
your friends and you can discover me you
know they'll just kind of like rattle
all the stuff off
but they will have no code none of it
will exist
and they'll get really frustrated
that we aren't pumped about that
like they don't like they're being too
optimistic that
the idea
that their articulation of this is
somehow
valuable or interesting
yes versus the implementation of it yes
that the deck that the idea has inherent
value as opposed to
and it's like
what's crazy is like man in one way that
gives us that shows they have a lot of
faith in us
the idea that we can just hear an idea
and know if it's gonna work or not like
don't you wish you had that power dalton
we need a little more
[Laughter]
what else falls in this category
i think
too much optimism
um around
thinking that because you raise some
amount of money whatever that is
yes is gonna save you
from
things not working or that your
investors are magical and will save you
like somehow they have magical powers
and so because i
you know because we raised from xyz
and again in this market this is more uh
maybe people will believe us more they
no one believed this a year ago no one
did no but
just because you raise a bunch of money
from important famous people does not
mean
all problems no longer exist and so you
see people being too optimistic where
they just turned off their brain once
they raised money that they would ever
they were just like hey i'm on easy
street man like we got it we nailed it
like we did it
yep um
and
if we hadn't done it why would these
folks have given us all this money
i love optimism also comes in the form
of hiring
we have this really big hairy kind of
awkward problem we don't understand well
but if we just hire a
marketing person a sales person this
person they will come in
and solve the biggest problem inside of
the company
especially pre-product market fit like
they will figure out what the product
should do or how people should find out
about it as a and what's weird is that
like
it's not like oh they'll help you or
together you'll figure it out even
um it's that no they'll do it that's why
you hire people
that's the like way to optimism like
like and it's often it's too optimistic
on multiple fronts one the idea that
your employees just like
hand you that
and two the idea that even if there
existed people out there who could you
could hire them in your like
pre-mvp startup or like pre-product
market if it's startup like
yeah like why why would the number one
marketing person in the world work for
you
at this stage they probably would
you know and the last one that i come up
with on the two optimistic front that i
see a lot is
but this is obviously going to work
because it's the cool thing
because it's the trending thing because
the thing investors are talking about on
twitter i should obviously work in this
category because it's the hot category
and
you know probably the one classic
example how many remote startups
and video conferencing startups did we
see
the second that covet hit
and
the thing that was so sad was like
having to explain to people
zoom
was working for years
before this moment so they could take
advantage of this moment
they have years head start technology
start all these advantages
not that they expected kovid would come
but they like they were they were in the
prime position for it you starting from
scratch after covid comes
you're optimizing for something that
probably happens post-covered
not something that's going to happen in
the next three to six nine 12 months
and i think that oftentimes founders you
know there are a lot of fads that way
we're a founder basically or people get
in at the end
and think that there's a lot to get when
like the reality is that
you want to get in before everyone
thinks it's cool not at the peak of
everyone thinking it's cool like the
peak of everyone thinking school is
usually right before
everything is the [ __ ] we sure see this
a lot of yc where
you can tell when something has jumped
the shark
when it is a one of the more common
ideas people apply with
like remember chat bots
everyone was building a chat bot for a
couple of years there
and that's when you knew it was over
basically
so
to wrap this up
let's come back to the message kind of
in the beginning
how do you have balance in this world
like how do you like we say balance but
aren't these aren't these
my is
i think this is a good idea but
it's going to be really hard and clear
evidence for this is is going to take a
while to develop these are kind of
hard to balance right
yeah i mean
i talk about the term cognitive
dissonance sometimes which again it's
another like psychology term and
cognitive dissonance is when you have
two conflicting ideas that you have to
hold on to at the same time and most
human beings don't like cognitive
dissonance it makes them
uncomfortable
to hold
conflicting ideas that
at the same time and i think i think the
best founders
have techniques and they can do it i
think and they can like be really good
at it i think
something to aspire for is a founder is
someone who can know
both
oh no like
my star employee just quit and says my
startup is horrible and
and now i don't know what i'm gonna do
but i'm gonna get on the sales call and
i'm gonna sell my heart out and like
close this customer
and
i have to kind of like
sit with both of like i have to be able
to do this and not go nutso
and like it's hard okay like
because like every day there's gonna be
crises of some sort right
and there's gonna be victories and the
people that screw this up they like
they can't handle that dissonance and
they go too far the way they resolve the
dissonance is to go too far one of the
one of the directions
of either like freaking out of the bad
things or
losing contact with reality more or less
you know a lot of founders i know i
wouldn't describe them as totally
enjoying that experience
but i would say that they figure out how
to thrive
in that environment like they execute in
that environment
and the risk in danger in some ways
um sharpens them
and how many times do we see founders
like
not bring their true a-game
until like shit's pretty bad it's like
actually
yes yes um
so there you go
so that's the blueprint right
be optimistic just don't be magically
optimistic yeah be rooted in reality
squarely rooted in real reality
all right man great shot
sounds good thanks
[Music]
[Music]
you